that's one of my very favorite parts of
Instagram is just writing really stupid
things sometimes I write things just to
make people choke on their coffee hi i'm
Jahan's anjali welcome to my studio I
own Geronimo balloons in Echo Park
California
I am Geronimo Geronimo is me it's
extension of whatever I'm interested
day-to-day I've always made things as a
way as an outlet my first balloon I ever
gave was from my best friend's birthday
about six years ago and I showed up to
the restaurant and I had a big balloon
inflated and people at the restaurant
just went wild
we do really crazy stuff any day or we
could be different we create backdrops
for photo shoots for TV we do parties we
do events we do branding for companies
when someone has like an idea or a need
we come in and we just like come up with
the craziest idea and hope that they say
yes when Kanye West wanted to have a
ceiling full of balloons we made it for
him for like a secret concert that he
was having
I love Instagram and I love engaging
with people through Instagram I love
watching what other people are doing
through Instagram you want a place to
kind of see if people are interested in
things you're doing so Instagram
immediately was a place that I could try
out new colors new ideas we had a huge
burst of people when one of the
Kardashians had a birthday party and
included us in her round of the favorite
things and so in the night I think we
had like 10 thousand extra followers
which shows the power of Instagram when
I think of what I want to be able to
achieve as an artist it's really not
about the visual product it's about this
feeling or the movement this idea this
place that I can create for people which
is Wonder I think as adults it's really
hard to like find wandering things
because we just like we've seen it all
we've experienced it all a little piece
of Wonder is what I want my legacy to be
or what I want like my art to be because
it just makes people happy it does I see
it and that is so fulfilling doing